el presidente chino ha dibujado un mundo
lleno de retos y de amenazas que
aconsejan mejorar el ejército y alcanzar
la autosuficiencia tecnológica no ha
mencionado Estados Unidos ni falta que
hace se sobreentiende que detrás de su
discurso están las alianzas militares
que Washington está formando en su patio
trasero o las restricciones a la compra
de Microchips y otros bienes
tecnológicos ha dicho Sí que el ejército
tiene que ser una gran Muralla de acero
que proteja la soberanía y la seguridad
del país que son marca la diferencia con
otros tiempos no tan lejanos en los que
potencias occidentales y Japón se
aprovecharon de su debilidad para
esquilmarla ha dicho Sí que el partido
comunista ha conseguido lavar aquello
humillación y que los chinos ahora ya
son dueños de su destino es un discurso
habitual que alude aquel siglo y medio
de colonización y que está todavía muy
presente en la memoria colectiva silla
alertó la semana pasada durante el
inicio de la asamblea nacional Popular
de que Estados Unidos estaba liderando
una coalición en occidente para frenar
el auge de China también ha recordado sí
que el proceso de rejuvenecimiento
nacional no terminará hasta que no se
consiga la reunificación con Taiwán Pero
ha utilizado un tono mucho más suave con
la isla ni siquiera usado la mención
habitual al uso de la fuerza como
recurso último